[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing one of the
many mysteries associated with albus
dumbledore's secretive past the
circumstances that surrounded the death
of his sister ariana i say many
mysteries because as you may recall it
became quite clear near the end of the
harry potter series that dumbledore had
many a secret let's start with some of
the more benign mysteries while harry
attended hogwarts dumbledore was a
mentor to the young wizard and yet for
most of the series he is frequently
unavailable to him
this in itself seems not quite right
does it
why would the headmaster of one of the
greatest magical schools in the world
constantly be absent where did he go and
what had he gone to do
it all seems a bit on the shady side if
you ask me then of course there were the
countless facts that dumbledore decided
not to share with our dear harry
including the truth about how he would
have to sacrifice himself in order to
defeat lord voldemort while i would
certainly consider this to be the most
ruthless secret dumbledore kept from the
boy there were countless others
including the fact that he decided to
give him to the darcys as a newly
offered infant and did nothing to expose
him to the truth of who he was until the
age of 11. i mean i do believe i could
go on and on about the things that
dumbledore kept secret and apparently so
could jk rowling i'm of course referring
to the upcoming third installment of
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore one does not need too much of
an imagination to conclude that we'll be
learning more about albus dumbledore's
secrets in this film
personally i am more than keen to
discover what else the great and
powerful dumbledore managed to cover up
last but certainly not least is the
900-page tell-all penned by the infamous
journalist rita skeeter released
immediately after his death with a title
like the life and lives of albus
dumbledore you can imagine that it most
certainly did not depict dumbledore in a
favorable manner spilling what she
thought to be a multitude of secrets
about albus and his family
in fact as you may recall this was the
publication which first told readers and
viewers alike about albus dumbledore's
close relationship with the future dark
wizard gelat grindelwald
the life and lives of albus dumbledore
is also the first time we learn about
albus's younger ailing sister
ariana dumbledore
alright so who is ariana dumbledore
aside from being albus's sister we know
that the dumbledore family never sent
her to hogwarts rita skeeter of course
thought that she was a squib a member of
a magical family who does not possess
any magical abilities of their own
this of course was not true ariana
actually had a great deal of power she
just didn't have any control over it as
you may recall from the deathly hallows
ariana was tragically attacked when she
was only six years old by a group of
three young mughals who saw her doing
magic
this attack traumatized ariana to the
point in which she would no longer
perform magic turning her abilities
inward on herself
this was incredibly dangerous and left
her magic uncontrollable as it would
escape from ariana in emotional
outbursts in my harry potter theory
video why harry wasn't an obscurial like
credence i recently discussed how the
description of ariana's illness matches
that of an obscurial so even though she
wasn't referred to as one in the harry
potter series that's most likely because
technically obscurials hadn't been
introduced to the wizarding world canon
yet
but in my opinion she most definitely
could be the inspiration behind credence
and obscurials in any case ariana lived
sequestered away in godric's hollow a
community in which most people didn't
even know that she existed her mother
would only allow her outside during the
dark of night in an effort to keep her
and her unpredictable nature safe it was
here that more tragedy struck the
dumbledore family
one day when ariana and her mother were
the only two home ariana went into a
rage accidentally killing her mother
with an explosion of magic at this point
in her life ariana was only 14 years old
which would be considered quite old for
an obscurial as witches and wizards who
harbour an obscurus typically don't live
into their teenage years that said she
was of course much too young and much
too unstable to live on her own her
father was unable to care for her as he
had been sent to azkaban for assaulting
the young muggles who had attacked
ariana when she was six he never
admitted to the reason behind his crime
before fear that the admission would
result in ariana being locked up so he
sadly died while incarcerated this left
albus as the next in line as her
guardian with great resentment
dumbledore returned to godric tollo to
care for his younger unwell sister
just as his life had been about to get
started
it was not long after while in his care
that ariana lost her life
and so while rita skeeter seemed most
interested in exposing the fact that the
dumbledore family kept ariana hidden
away the real mystery even to those who
were there was in fact who killed ariana
dumbledore for those who may not know
present the time of ariana's death was
albus his younger brother aberforth and
gelet grindelwald you may be thinking
well then it must be quite obvious one
of these three wizards killed ariana
leaving two witnesses to testify and
corroborate each other's stories and yet
it is not quite so simple as that here
in aberforth's words you see how the
events of that terrible day are anything
but clear i pulled out my wand and he
pulled out his and i had the cruciatus
curse used on me by my brother's best
friend
and albus was trying to stop him and
then all three of us were dueling and
the flashing lights and the bangs set
her off she couldn't stand it
the color was draining from aberfor's
face as though he had suffered a mortal
wound
and i think she wanted to help but she
didn't really know what she was doing
and i don't know which of us did it it
could have been any of us and she was
dead so aberforth names himself albus
and grindelwald as the three wizards who
could have killed her and yet he isn't
at all certain in fact none of them are
years later while visiting harry in
death even albus admits that he never
fully knew who killed her in truth he
was always immensely fearful of what had
actually happened that day
it was the truth i feared you see i
never knew which of us in that last
horrific fight had actually cast the
curse that killed my sister i dreaded
beyond all things the knowledge that it
had been i who brought about her death
so it seems that we will never know the
truth of who whether it was one of her
brothers or gelet ended ariana's life
and yet it would be so easy to blame
grindelwald future dark wizard who
harboured ill will towards others whom
he didn't see as his equal we see this
demonstrated again and again throughout
the fantastic beasts series
so why should we assume that he would
have viewed ariana any differently
well my answer to that is if she was in
fact an obscurial he may have valued the
powerful dark magic that existed inside
of her similarly to how he values
credence in fantastic beasts so then
perhaps it would be easiest to say that
it truly was an accident with no one to
blame ariana was tragically in the wrong
place at the wrong time unable to
control her parasitical magic in the
face of such an intense fight the three
wizards would have had to have done
something to protect themselves from her
outburst
after all she had previously killed her
mother in a similar explosion of emotion
so an accident a reflex from one or
possibly all three men in an effort to
shield themselves from harm seems
reasonable
in which case we again can't clearly
name one of them as clearly responsible
for her death seems likely that we'll
never truly know how it all unfolded we
can simply narrow it down to three
possibilities but before i wrap up this
video let me leave you with one more
thought if ariana was an obscurial is it
not possible that her final outburst of
uncontrollable emotion and power is what
killed her think about it when an
obscurial releases its obscurus it's
most often released as an invisible
destructive wind so even though
fantastic beasts credence physically
transforms into his obscurus this type
of transformation is only known to
happen in extremely rare cases meaning
that ariana could have released her
obscurus without anyone seeing it only
to meet her own end after all most
obscurials did not survive their youth
so perhaps neither the dumbledore
brothers nor gaelic grindelwald killed
her at all
perhaps ariana is the one responsible
for her own death
and with that we're at the end of
another video as always i'd love to know
what you think let me know your thoughts
in the comments below and as always if
you enjoyed the video don't forget to
like and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember
happiness can be found even in the
darkest of times if one only remembers
to turn on the light
[Music]
you